having said that
i want to talk a little bit more about
my impatience because i do have a lot of
impatience right now
and nearly all of it is directed at
attorney general merrick
garland merrick garland as a.g is the
top law enforcement official here in the
united states
has so far
not
gone after donald trump in any kind of
meaningful way
sure the fake elector investigation is
obviously leading up to trump it has to
i mean he's the guy at the top of it
but we have had plenty of people
including those serving on the january 6
committee by the way so this isn't just
me being impatient this is also people
on the committee saying hi
we've got all of this wonderful material
for you
could you do something
and what has been merrick garland's
response well as he told us last week
i'm watching the hearings
i'm watching them
we're paying attention
so the attorney general of the united
states is out there telling us like
don't worry folks
i'm tuning in to cnn every day just like
you
no no no that's that's not good merrick
i don't want you
to be learning this stuff the same way
that i am
okay again you're the attorney general
you should probably i don't know maybe
be present in the room
i mean i'm sure they'd be willing to
give you a pass to go sit in the room
while they're doing the hearings
and if not you probably know somebody
that could get you one
you know we don't want the attorney
general
to sit there and say ah don't worry
folks i'm watching tv just like the rest
of you
well that's wonderful if we're
talking about the season of miss marvel
that's currently on but
we're talking about the january 6
committee hearings
you should already know what's happening
there should be sharing of information
maybe that's on garland maybe that's on
the committee but the bottom line is
that they have already and the judges of
course have confirmed this and we've
talked about it i know david's talked
about it everybody's talked about it
the judges who've looked at this have
already said there's evidence of
criminal behavior here right now
right now
we have it we've got it
but merrick garland so far has not
opened up a single investigation into
donald trump himself for his actions
here
and that is
forever frustrating
and to me there there's no excuse for
that
no excuse
the january 6 committee
is only going to be able to continue
doing their job for a couple more months
eventually they will have to kind of put
it on pause so they can all go and
campaign
i mean
they're in the house they all have to
campaign except for the the you know
folks that aren't running anymore and
they're leaving after this so they're
gone anyway
and republicans unfortunately are poised
to take back over the house of
representatives they've made it clear
they do that committee's over with
so what garland should do and i know i
pitched this i think the last time i i
guess posted on david's show here back
in december but merrick garland should
have already appointed a special
prosecutor
that's all you need
you give them the time you give them the
budget you give them the funds you give
them whatever they need but most
importantly you give it
time
because the january 6 committee does not
have time the january 6 committee has
wasted so much time having to go to
court
to battle these people who don't want to
comply with the subpoenas a special
prosecutor wouldn't have that problem
right a grand jury wouldn't have that
problem
it would be so much easier for a special
prosecutor to be appointed by merrick
garland to walk into that january 6
committee and say listen you guys have
done phenomenal work
i'm going to take it from here
thank you for everything you've done
thank you for everything you've given us
but i've got this don't worry
and in fact appoint two or three special
prosecutors there's a bunch of different
avenues bunch of different schemes that
do need to be investigated and it'd be
great to have a separate person on each
and every one of them
folks i've been screaming about that for
eight nine months now
and we still haven't gotten it
and the only person standing in the way
of that
is of course unfortunately
the attorney general of the united
states merrick
garland
we cannot have any
any
forward progress
without his say-so